I'm Chuck Wolfe and I am an assistant scoutmaster with Troop 342 in Raleigh, North Carolina.
This edition of the Scoutmaster podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
Thanks for everything you do, Clark.
And now the old scoutmaster.
Three scouters are taking a hike through the forest. There's two men and a woman
and they're hiking through the forest and they reach the bank of this raging river.
And the first man looks around and he says: a scout is prepared and he takes his axe
and he starts chopping the entries to pioneer a bridge across the river.
And the second man sees this and he thinks: hmm, I can do better than that.
And he says: a scout is brave. and he prepares to jump in the river
and swim across this raging torrent.
And the woman looks at her map and walks 20 yards upstream and crosses the footbridge.
You know, the first time I told that joke, I was told that I might
have a corner taken off of my man card.
But it's true, isn't it?
Yes, it is.
Hey, welcome to podcast number 225..
Hey,
Well, welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look at the mailbag. This week we heard from Tom Routh
who said thanks for all you do, for scouting. The resources you've compiled are invaluable.
I was looking for a scout circle video from last October, but I couldn't seem to find it.
Is it still available?
Well, Tom, I did the same thing. I couldn't find it either.
You know, we've tried doing the scout circle presentations on Google Plus
and sometimes it works really well and sometimes things get a little mixed up somehow
And I really don't know what's happened to that October video.
I have had a couple of questions in the past couple of weeks about scout circle.
Hey, where's scout circle? Are we going to see a new presentation anytime soon?
And the answer is: I've just had to lay that aside for the time being,
until I can get my collaborators together and we can put together a new presentation for you.
And we're hitting the busy season for scouting right now.
We've got summer camp coming up and a trip to Switzerland coming up.
So whether or not we're going to see a new scout circle soon is a question,
But I've got a couple other interesting projects that I'm working on that I'll tell you
more about in future podcasts and that you'll see online.
Dan wrote in to say just a note to say thank you for the valuable info and resources you've
made accessible to all leaders in scouting. I'm still relatively new to scouting
and I'm looking for resources to work on my not tying skills in other areas
such as camping and hiking and things like that.
Well, Dan, hopefully we can help you out a little bit.
There's lots of great resources on the web.
One of the really good places to look I have found for stuff like that is go to YouTube
and search for a specific skill.
It's pretty astounding the amount of information that's out there.
Of course, some of the information isn't all that great,
but there are some really good resources out there that I have found in the past.
Heard from Jim Gregg, who's the scout master with Troop 199 in Old Wick, New Jersey,
And Jim sent me some pictures of his scouts playing a game that we posted about,
oh I guess, back a couple months ago, called the Whirling Jackstay.
It was actually in one of Enoch Highsey's posts about scout games
And the Whirling Jackstay. I can't really describe it in a podcast,
but it's a pretty active game.
But anyway, Jim sent me some pictures- entertaining pictures- of his scouts playing that game.
He said: you continue to make an impression on our scouts, on their ribs and their backs
and their legs.
It's a very fun game, the Whirling Jackstay and the boys played it at our Troop meeting this week.
Thanks again for all you do.
Well, thank you, Jim.
It certainly gave me a laugh.
It's a great game
And it's one of those games. you know that's kind of rough and tumble
And hopefully it didn't leave too many marks,
but I'm sure they had fun doing it.
I have the chat feature live over at scoutmastercgcom this week.
Every once in a while when I'm working at my desk,
I'll turn on the live chat so that, if you're online at the time,
we can have a chance just to chat a little bit.
And I chatted this week with Hank from Troop 74 in Tucson, Arizona,
and Cody from Troop 246 at Cypress, Texas.
We were all three on the chat at the same time and we had a great discussion.
I really appreciate you guys checking in with me.
It's difficult to tell when you're online chatting with people
exactly who those people are.
But Hank from Arizona- I'm pretty sure that was Hank Schrader from Breaking Bad,
if you know what I'm talking about.
And Cody from Texas- I can't be sure,
but it could have been Buffalo Bill Cody, right.
I mean, who knows,
Next time you're on the website at scoutmastercgcom,
check the chat feature see if we're live.
If we're not, you can always leave a message
And we always appreciate hearing from everybody.
Heard from Robin, who said
I've gone back to podcast one to listen to them all.
I'm currently on number 39, still can't get enough.
Thanks again. such an inspiration.
Well, thank you, Robin.
I know a lot of people go back and they work their way
through number one all the way up to,
I guess. well, let's see, we're at 225 right now.
So that's a big investment of time
and I really appreciate people doing that
And I'm glad that they get something out of it.
It's great.
On the blog this past week- let's see here-
We posted a new infographic about outdoor footwear-
just some basics that can help you make choices.
If you haven't seen that, check it out.
Got good response and a lot of interest
And that infographic is now part of the Scoutmaster CG PDF package
And that's available at scoutmastercgcom.
It has over 40 infographics and useful PDFs for Scouters.
They run the gamut of things like training youth leaders
to knots and games and camping know-how.
It's just a ton of stuff.
And go to scoutmastercgcom and follow the link
that you'll see in the right hand column to the PDF package,
Also posted, about scouting in a dirty old duck puddle.
How about that for a title?
The idea was based on a couple of quotes from Baden Powell
about the kind of nature and temperament of the ideal scouter,
And I found it really interesting
and I had some thoughts about those quotes.
We did a review of David Scott's new book
My Fellow Americans: Scouting and the Presidency this past week
And if you haven't seen the book yet,
I really recommend it highly.
David's put together a very interesting narrative
of the relationship between the BSA
and the United States presidency over the past 100 years,
And there's some really interesting stories and facts in there.
If you're a fan of scouting history, you'll enjoy the read,
And if you're a fan of scouting, you'll enjoy the read.
The review is online at scoutmastercgcom,
So make sure you get online and go over and check it out.
You can also see the post that we put up
and listen to the podcast and everything.
It's available from iTunes for Apple iPhones and iPads
And it's also available for any Android device on Google Play.
So get the app and you'll be able to keep everything
that we make right there at your fingertips on your mobile device
And within this past week
we've had a couple of new scoutmaster CG backers. sign on,
Let me explain something.
If you buy the PDF package,
I also make it possible for you to make a backer sponsorship announcement.
I'm not going to read off every single name
of the people who buy the PDF package
Because if I did that it would take 10 or 15 minutes a week,
So I'm just not going to be able to make that happen.
But people who choose the other levels of becoming a backer,
I want to make sure to recognize them
Now. the funds that we get from backers
go towards the expenses of producing and publishing
all the resources that we make available at scoutmastercgcom.
Keep them freely available to scouts all over the world.
If you've gotten something from the blog and the podcast
and the other resources that we've created
and you'd like to return the favor, become a backer,
Go to scoutmastercgcom,
follow the support link at the top of the page
and you'll get all the details on how to make that happen.
And within this past week
I want to make sure to thank Steve Sanders and Hank Rees
for signing up and becoming backers.
Really do appreciate it.
Let's see
On this week's podcast,
have a couple of good emails to answer,
and that's going to take up the rest of the podcast,
So let's get started. shall we?
Tip me over and pull me out?
Tip me over and pull me out.
Write me a letter, send it by name
Email. that is, folks,
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
Now, both of the emails I'm going to answer this week
deal with slightly tickler situations.
Both of the people who sent them to me
asked me to keep them anonymous,
And so I'm definitely going to do that.
First email I was I want to look at this week
came to me from a committee member
and she said:
I've been reading your site,
which comes highly recommended
by the other adults in our troupe.
I was appointed to help as a committee member
with some tasks that are clearly defined
in the troupe bylaws
and procedures that we've created.
I've repeatedly tried to get information.
I need to do the work I've taken on,
but I've been told this information
is only for the boys to handle.
I was told it's better let them fail
in a safe environment than to step in
and try and micromanage things.
Frankly, I'm a little lost here.
I simply am trying to help make things happen
And I do think it's important
to let scouts make these decisions.
but allowing one scout to fail
because he doesn't provide information
to learn a lesson at the expense of all the others
doesn't seem appropriate to me.
Is boy led really that way?
It seems very disrespectful
of the interest of a lot of other people
to allow scouts to fail
to deliver the program to them.
Am I completely out of line?
I'm really trying to figure this out.
I'd appreciate any insight
you might be willing to provide.
I'm not sure the headache of swimming upstream
against some very domineering men
is worth the stress of trying to be helpful.
Well, it sounds to me
like you're being asked to aim at a moving target
and I'm really sorry
things aren't working out all that well.
Let's see if I can be any help at all,
because it appears that I may have been responsible
for creating the problem in the first place.
Now, leaving my opinion of bylaws
and other things like that aside,
because I don't see a whole lot
of purpose to them in scouting,
It appears that you've been asked
to take on a set of tasks
that clearly require some kind of definition,
some kind of information upfront,
And it seems perfectly reasonable
that you ask for that information.
As you well know,
I'm a strong advocate of scouts
leading and planning their own activities
and the teaching opportunity
that failures and missteps represent,
But sometimes-
and I think you describe a pretty good example-
this all gets taken to its logical absurdity.
Now, before I go any further,
I want to really cheerfully acknowledge
that I've been just as guilty of doing this as anyone,
So this isn't really a stinging rebuke
to the laudable intentions that are involved
on the part of the other adults you're working with.
I would suggest, though,
that maybe they need to rethink things
and make a couple of course adjustments.
What folks miss
is the kind of response of leadership
that's required in situations like this.
I mean, if, after multiple attempts
to get some action on a matter,
there's zero response from the youth leadership,
we're going to need to respond
because, as you've stated,
there's more than just their interests
and their development in question.
There's another of other scouts
and families involved in this too.
Now, there have been plenty of times
in the past 30 years
my patrol leaders council
has just totally dropped the ball.
They've done absolutely nothing.
Now, when this happens,
I don't just say,
well, this is a boy led thing
and we can't really do too much about it.
No, I have a frank heart to heart
with the senior patrol leader
and I tell him in no uncertain terms:
you need to get moving.
And normally he will take a step
in my direction.
It might not be a whole lot,
but he moves a little bit
and I respond with all kinds
of supporting and encouragement.
Sometimes this is like pulling teeth
and sometimes it involves
a lot of hand holding
and sometimes feeding them information
to work with.
but I need to get them
in the process of doing it.
I'm looking for the least indication
of initiative in building on it.
You can't just necessarily,
in every situation like this,
draw a hard line and say,
well, unless they do a,
we're not going to do B.
No, sometimes you have to make a happen
and then build on the initiative
that they respond with.
Simply letting things like this slide
for weeks at a time
is not right
And it approaches the logical absurdity
that I mentioned earlier.
If this was a football team
and the team showed up
and they just laid down on the sidelines
with the coaches just say:
well, you know, it's their decision,
There's nothing we can do about it?
No, I hope not.
I hope they'd make some demands
and issue some directions,
And sometimes that's what needs to happen,
Not as a matter of habit,
where the adults are making
all the decision,
issuing all the directions
and constantly micromanaging
everything that the scouts do,
But sometimes, if youth leaders
are unresponsive,
they need to be encouraged
in every way possible
to make a response,
And then you build on that.
While it's true
we should foster and encourage
youth engagement,
It's never an on and off switch.
There's a lot of different levels
of ability and leadership
and experience
and the appropriate responses
to those levels.
that's demanded of us.
Now, I don't understand
how anybody who's part of a committee
and has been tasked
with things that require information
beforehand
can overstep their bounds
by asking for that information.
I mean, it doesn't seem
very logical to me.
How exactly is a perfectly
reasonable request like that?
Somehow you're surping
the scouts ability
to make decisions.
I don't see it.
I hope this begins
to shed a little bit of light
on the matter.
In short,
it appears to me that
the attentions of the adults
involved are good.
They're just getting the execution
flawed a little bit.
Not knowing any of the personalities
or mitigating circumstances
involved,
I don't want to cast my advice
of judgment about who's right
or wrong,
but these are observations
based on what you've told me
and my own experience,
because you know
I've been as guilty of this
as anyone else.
I want to take notice
of your statement
about domineering men
and, in as much as it's possible,
let me apologize for them.
I know it's not
really possible,
but perhaps it helps a little
to let you know
that I do understand
what you're talking about.
I've observed men and boys
working together
and scouting for a long time now
and there are many different
attitudes and actions
to be overcome. sometimes
Many of us men mistake
being compassionate or helpful
for being unmanly.
Many of us think we need
to make a scout's way
difficult because
this will somehow
help them become tough
and be a man.
But to be brutally honest,
we sometimes get
disappointed and angry
with our sons
and with our scouts
because we see a lot of ourselves
in them.
It's a painful thing for us
and sometimes we react
by striking back
with meanness and harshness
instead of responding
with some compassion
and understanding.
I think men a lot of times
distrust compassion
because we fear
it will make our boys soft,
It will make them somewhat
less than real men.
We fear the apron strings
of childhood
and we feel it's important
to break them,
and the way we do that
isn't very pretty sometimes,
Frankly. there are a lot of us
who imitate our own upbringing
and in our parenting-
for good or ill,
because it's all we really know.
There's always been a
tension between men and women,
mothers and fathers
about this type of thing,
and that tension is just
as real and scouting
as anywhere else.
What we all ought to do,
men and women alike,
is to take stock
of our own reactions
and feelings
and do our best
to rise to the higher ideals
and potential in the scout oath and law.
What you come to realize
as a scouter
is that you are growing
and developing
and learning
right along with the scouts.
It's pretty amazing
and it's a pretty great thing
about being involved in scouting.
The second email I received
was from a gentleman
who said this:
I've just accepted the request
to become a scout master
and I hope to guide our troop
away from adult leadership
towards the scouts
leading themselves.
I have purchased the book
Working the Patrol Method
and I will read it as soon as I get it.
Can you let me know
if there are any other resources
that may help.
I want to also know
what training is best
to do first
as a new scout master,
and what's the best course
for training youth leaders.
Well, first of all,
congratulations on becoming a scout master.
It's great fun,
It's a big challenge.
Now, whatever has happened
in the past
and whatever your ambitions
for the future
of the troop,
your first responsibility
is always delivering
the program to the scouts,
And I think you get that.
I'll hazard the guess
that, based on what I hear and see,
the majority of scouts
are members and troops
just like yours,
that kind of are more adult
than youth, led,
maybe not really applying
the patrol system
and just kind of chugging along
like they always have.
I'd agree that this isn't
necessarily the optimal experience,
but remember,
it's not doing any harm.
as a matter of fact,
it's doing a lot of good.
My point is
this isn't an emergency.
Things are not going to change
into what you'd like to see quickly.
It's going to take a little time
and it will require a lot of
forbearance and patience
on your part.
Now it's going to be great fun
and things are going to change,
but I'm just going to encourage
you: don't rush,
don't push
and don't fret too much.
Stay on the course.
make these changes,
work with your scouts
and you're going to get there.
You've got a good start
with the patrol method book.
it's a great resource
and I'm going to send you a copy
of my book,
The Scouting Journey,
see if that helps.
As for which training to take first,
you know it's fairly kind of
dry
what a scout master needs
to be considered trained.
so I would do that course of training
and then take whatever time allows.
do it all.
take all the online training
that you can,
take all the in-person training
that you can.
It certainly won't hurt, right?
As for what training course
I recommend for youth leaders,
I really don't.
I don't think that youth leaders
respond very well
to that kind of event-based
or course-based training.
A lot of skills they need
actually come pretty easy to them
if you give them some space to develop.
Now let me get on my soapbox
here for a second.
How do you show somebody
how to tie a square knot?
You don't sit them down
to a PowerPoint presentation
on the history of
cordage
and knotting theory, right.
You get a rope
and you show them.
How do you
share a game
or a song with scouts?
Do you sit them down?
sit them down
and draw a diagram of the game
and go through all the rules
and permutations of the game,
or do you start playing
and learn as you go along?
If you're going to teach
scouts to sing a song,
do you hand out song sheets
and rehearse the harmonies
before you start,
or do you just start singing?
I just start singing. personally,
Scouts don't want
or care much about theory.
They want action.
Now, this is not to say
that it's a
that a little instruction is bad.
I don't say that's bad,
but what needs to come first
is action.
You won't fix things
by sitting all the youth leaders
down on a weekend
and describing how things
are going to change,
because we aren't talking
about throwing a switch here.
Right,
It isn't that easy.
What happens
if you show up
at the next scout meeting
and you ask the senior
patrol leader what his job is?
Ask him to tell you
What does he think his job is,
What does he think
he should be doing
that he's not doing
And what would he like
to stop doing?
I mean, maybe it's just
making announcements
at the closing of the meeting,
or something simple
that the adults are used to doing
that the scout should take over,
If you handle this right
in your discussion
with the senior patrol leader.
he's going to go home
thinking it was his idea all along.
Of course you'll have to
corral the adults
and get them to stop
doing some things,
and that can be a bigger challenge.
But they chose you
to become the scout master
and they're going to follow
your directions.
Maybe not at first,
maybe not joyfully,
but ultimately
they're going to get on board.
Don't drop hints
or ask questions of adults.
You give them directions.
Here's a key thing to remember
and I've often repeated it here:
The scout master mentors
and coaches as youth leaders,
but he directs
and leads adults.
Of course you'll be
good natured and affable,
but firm.
when you're talking with adults,
You're jumping into the volcano.
It's hot in here
and it's challenging,
hard work,
but it's great fun.
It's really great fun.
I hope all this makes sense.
I wish I could give you
three easy steps to success,
but I can't.
95% of your work
as a scouter
is attitude
and spirit.
The skills and knowledge
come with experience,
but only if you approach
the work
in the right spirit
and with the right attitude.
Do you have a question
or conundrum
that I might be able
to help you out with?
Well,
you can get in touch with me,
and you're going to find out
how to do that
in just a moment.
You've been listening to the
225th edition
of the Scoutmaster podcast.
Here's how to keep in touch.
Read the blog
at scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there,
you can subscribe
to receive updates
to the blog
by email,
either on a daily basis
or once a week.
Get the Scoutmaster CG app
that I talked about earlier
on Google Play
or at the iTunes app store,
And remember
you can experience
the wonders of
scoutmastercgcom
through the vast
panorama
of social media outlets.
You can join the 5700 folks
who like Scoutmaster blog
on Facebook.
Tweet along with the chorus
of 1,050
tweeters on Twitter.
Pin the poultry tuna's
pictures, profiled publicly
with 1,600 other
prolific pinners
on Pinterest.
Watch as if you dare
at ScoutmasterCG
on YouTube,
or join the 400 odd folks
who form the exclusive
ScoutmasterCG circle
on Google Plus.
Now, if you can't face Facebook,
if Twitter makes you better,
if you have no interest
in Pinterest,
If you don't put the? U in YouTube,
if you're a minus
when it comes to Google Plus,
that's alright. Bunky,
Zoom into the late 90s
and send me an email.
That's right.
You can email me,
Clark Green,
with your comments
and questions
and wild ideas
at clark.
at scoutmastercgcom,
It's C-L-A-R-K-E
It only remains
for me to remind you
the Scoutmaster blog
and the Scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed
or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America
or any other
scouting organization
for that matter.
I'm sure they have much better things
to do with their time.
No, it's just me
talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand
to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun
along the way.
and speaking of fun,
let's hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you
and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir.
Until next time, everyone.